it's really hard with kanye the
kardashians just dropped a new trailer
for their upcoming hulu series and
they're talking love breakups and babies
people tune in because you never know
what's going to happen the famous fam
teases what fans will see when the
kardashians debuts on hulu april 14th
and yes we're getting a closer look at
the moment travis barker popped the
question to courtney on the beach in
montecito california one of the biggest
things in her life is about to happen
and courtney has no idea
and get this a previous trailer for the
new show revealed that the love birds
are ready to have a baby together travis
and i want to have a baby
yeah that's the 42 year old reality star
and the 46 year old drummer at the
doctor's office talking about having a
little one of their own back in february
a source told et that court and trav are
so in love and are open to the idea of
having children together and growing
their family i'm just like living life
and
whatever happens happens
of course courtney shares three kids
with her ex scott disick 12 year mason
nine-year-old penelope and
seven-year-old reign while travis has
two kids of his own with his ex shayna
mokler 18 year old landon and 16 year
old alabama my children are my first
priority and you know that's one thing
that you know travis and i you know do
agree on you know our children come
first and their happiness and as long as
you know the kardashians are good to my
kids you know that's all that matters to
me as a mom and while fans can expect to
see the pooch founders love blossom we
can also expect to hear more about kim's
split from kanye west
it's really hard with kanye
the 41 year old kkw beauty founder filed
for divorce after six years of marriage
back in february 2021 and while she
seemingly tried to keep their issues
private i'm just rolling with it and it
is what it is the 44 year old rapper has
thrown a slew of online attacks at his
estranged wife and her new boyfriend
saturday night live star pete davidson
god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
but kim isn't the only one talking all
things heartbreak
i'm not here to play games from the
looks of it that drama between chloe and
her ex tristan thompson will play out on
the family's new show too
tristan and i are complicated trust
takes time you'll recall in january the
nba star admitted to fathering a child
with another woman while he and coco
were still together
and the 37 year old good american
founder who shares a three-year-old
daughter true with tristan previously
told variety that she won't shy away
from discussing it quote it's not a fun
thing to talk about but it is part of my
journey in life so we will see it on the
show that's how it should be as for
kylie jenner fans can expect to see more
of her pregnancy journey with baby
number two i am very excited to have
another baby the 24 year old beauty
mogul welcomed her second child a son
with travis scott back in february
and a source previously told et the
lovebirds have wanted to grow their
family for a while now and couldn't be
happier
[Music]
you